it is time for drew's news your daily
good news floss of those pearly white
news teeth and with me at the desk is
every dentist's dreams rossi always
flossy matthews
[Applause]
first up who is the number one favorite
celebrity amongst america's teens who is
it it's adam sandler
i know
insider reports that adam sandler came
out on top in a massive survey of 10 000
teens from across the entire country
thanks to streamers like netflix teens
are watching older sandler super hits
like billy madison and happy gilmore
plus his new movies on netflix like
murder mystery with jen aniston i did a
couple movies with adam yeah right
hello i love it the wedding singer i
just watched last week it's so good drew
oh thank you and 50 first dates which we
love and also do you know what's fun is
when adam and i decided to do blended we
both had children at that point we
thought okay we'll have we'll be parents
in this movie and what's so funny is now
it's all like young kids who come up to
us about blended and then their families
are like oh my god we've had to watch it
50 times really and it it kind of uh i
think helped us meet a new generation
and um
one sandler stan actually posted this
video on tick tock for her birthday she
made the dress code adam sandler oh and
what's so hilarious is i am telling you
since the first day i met adam
20 something years ago he dresses
exactly the same today
as he did then he likes his long shorts
and his long t-shirts and nothing is
going to break his stride i love him you
know i've never met him but i walked by
him in a parking lot once and you and i
was like oh my god i'm sander and you
know what he said hey ross like that i
was like hi i think he just walked by
why
and you know we also love the holidays
and if you're going to have a house
guest and you need to figure out where
to clean first right do you do that
where you panic and you run around well
apartment therapy says new research use
an eye tracker to scientifically measure
which parts of a room people pay the
most attention to
science put to work right so you walk
into them they check where are you
looking well in the kitchen people look
to the floor
really yeah and in the living room
people look at the coffee table so clear
up that clutter i have a glass coffee
table and i'm obsessed with fingerprints
on it my grandma who we call bunka she's
95 she watches every day hi hi
hi
i remember growing up we had a she had a
screen door that was like glass you know
and we'd always run outside and she'd
just stay there with a paper towel as
we'd walk in and out i remember thinking
she's crazy and now here i am with a
paper towel and windex
oh here's another one in the bathroom
you know what they say they look at the
most in the bathroom
i thought it would be the sink right
it's the mirror
i will say this um
whenever i used to date a guy way back
in the day i would look at his bathroom
floor you would yes
i just i was always like
did nobody mention like brooms mops
vacuums i feel like that's like the sign
of like younger people is having like
those weird little like cotton things in
the corner of the bathroom i don't know
am i alone here no
has anyone dated a guy when they were
younger and thought have you had do you
own a vacuum
yeah okay i love you it's a sign of
young love when you're dating someone
and their bathroom floor is a mess
it's like a woman's right of passage i
understand why or a young girl's right a
passage yeah you may be cute when you're
younger and that's so cute when you're
40. no no no no okay
next story uh for many people over the
last year and a half the pandemic
allowed for a time to rethink our lives
and careers and as a result
tons of people are making big changes
and cbs news reports that the great
resignation is happening across america
and
four million people quit in july alone
wow
and some young people have actually
headed towards a farm
some college grads say that the more
work
that they do on the farm the more
meaningful that they feel their lives
have become
ross thoughts well i'm not moving to a
farm
but i do think you know the real the
real question here is in this time that
has been so unprecedented have we all
taken a chance to look and thought think
to ourselves what do i really want for
me was about my health you know i i
think i got my body together a little
bit during this time because it was what
do i want i want to be here i want to be
here and that's the decision i made so i
think anyone watching or reading this
article we're talking about should ask
them that question what do we want if
anything came out of this time it was a
pause on the world to focus on ourselves
again so i love that people are doing
this i i won't be on the farm but
congratulations to you oh gosh well next
up it is time to do a live review of the
things you want us to do this is drew's
reviews
[Music]
okay this is so fun today's pick is from
kelly morrison via instagram and it's
the rug leaf scooper it comes with two
scoops one per hand and it's meant to
pick up leaves that your breeze brings
into the room okay
okay it's like look
should we try out these pac-man hands oh
100 high five by the way
yes okay let's try it we got some leaves
right here all right you ready let's see
and oh
[Music]
oh my goodness
um oh i really this is very satisfying
satisfying i could do this all day me
too
um so what do you think dude do you love
this are you gonna leaf it alone
i'm not going to leave it right i'm
going to love it i love it i'm giving
this five stars
i give it the same this is a five star
oh my god it's so gratifying
we'll have this on our website by the
way look
you just go right into fixing your hair
these will be on our website at the
dreamwormrow show.com and we'll be right
back with you as well
[Music]
you